we're joined now by the conservative MP
and chair of the women and equalities
committee Caroline notes lovely to have
you on the program hello
um there's so much that we could talk
about but it feels like we should start
with the conference that was on this
week the International Conference full
of lots of really inspirational speakers
about violence against women and girls
in conflict and there's been a lot of
talk about wartime rape in particular
and you know how much of an issue is it
and do you think things are getting
better
oh no I don't think things are getting
better and I really wish they were I
think the steps that we've seen from 50
countries coming together at the
beginning of this week with the UK
leading the way on the Declaration I
think that's progress but what we really
need to see is a cultural approach where
we would all recognize that rape sexual
assault violence against women and girls
as part of conflict is absolutely
abhorrent what we also need to make sure
is that
Russian soldiers for example in Ukraine
are respecting that but across the whole
globe and I think back to when William
Hague was foreign secretary and really
was leading the way on discussing rape
as a weapon of war and it just feels
like globally we've made too little
progress so I really welcome the money
that's going to go in we've seen I think
12 and a half million pounds committed
by the UK government 10 million dollars
from the us but we need to have a
cultural approach to supporting
survivors Justice uh measures making
sure that evidence is collected both
effectively and ethically and I've seen
all that in the Declaration this week
but I think we still got a long way to
go yeah um Angela and jolly um described
this week the lack of action by
governments to support survivors is
deeply painful and frustrating I mean we
would all agree with these assessments
but I guess just listen to you talking
about you know the actions of individual
Russian soldiers for example it's so
difficult isn't it to do anything about
what is effectively actions of
individuals
well there is some very serious
allegations about whether in Ukraine
rape is used being used as a systematic
weapon of War so actually there I think
there has to be a the collection of
evidence they have to be brought to
trial we need to see international
criminal courts convened to deal with
that
um but you know Russia's turning itself
into a real Pariah state from which you
have to question whether there's any
route back and what do you think that
means in in reality
what I think in reality it means yet
more probably Decades of sanctions it
means more action by the West against
Russia I think uh inevitably we need to
be making sure that Ukraine has the
resources it needs we've done some great
work over the last uh
10 months uh trying to support Ukraine
making sure that troops have the
training that they need but it's um it's
just such a horrendous situation and
there's so much that I want to talk to
you about
um including what your committee is
looking into
um but there's been a lot of debate
recently about the online harms bill
um which is all about safety online
effectively and something that you know
women and girls feel very strongly about
it can feel like a place where there's
an awful lot of misogyny if you take
misogyny intervene hatred of women
um do you think that there is a risk the
online harms well it's been watered down
or are you more in the camp that says
look there is a balance to be struck
between harm online and freedom of
speech
well look I want to do online harms
legislation that's going to be effective
I want to see something that is going to
protect children that's an absolute must
as far as I'm concerned I think there
are some good measures in it around
coercive control making that a priority
offense around uh sharing of intimate
images deep fakes I've been really
pleased cyber flashing I'm really
pleased to see the engagement that
Michelle Donovan's had on that I think
with legislation like this we all want a
bit more don't we and there is I think
the more important balance to be struck
is between making sure that the
regulator is effective making sure that
there are enforcement powers that are
actually going to put the onus on the
social media Giants to make sure that
children are off their platform
um and I I think it's really difficult I
think we have to be realistic about this
that as soon as we legislate there will
be some geek somewhere in the world will
be looking for routes around whatever
legislation is put in place
um you've also been looking at sexism
and football in your committee it feels
something that we should be talking
about right now with the World Cup what
have you been looking at oh look we had
some um really
startling evidence I think it was a
fortnight ago from Fern wheeling and
Susie rack he was a very prominent
Sports journalist talking about the uh
the blatant misogyny that they'd faced
uh the contrast between comments that
they would make uh when reporting on
matches and a male commentator would
make exactly the same comment and get no
abuse I think Susie rack gave us a a
beautiful
demonstration of some of the abuse that
she's faced you know and some of those
typical sexist tropes of get back to the
kitchen love but actually far more
Insidious vile uh threats and commentary
against them and I I think we've got
some brilliant examples haven't we the
England women's team winning the Euros
Jill Scott winning uh I'm a celebrity
and these are women who are real
Trailblazers and have set the standard I
think one of the really fascinating
things was the cultural differences
between the man's game and the women's
game I went to the quarterfinal where
England beat Spain and it there was a
fantastic family atmosphere contrast
that with Fern Whelan saying to us that
until facilities and attitudes improve
she doesn't take us onto football
matches anymore that is quite depressing
actually isn't it I mean some people are
listening you know will have heard the
you know the very very serious stuff
that we spoke about at the beginning
then they'll be listening to you know
this I'll talk about women in football
we'll be like look it doesn't really
matter it's a big deal you know is it a
big deal yeah it is a big deal because
it's about the culture it's about
misogyny it's about the way uh women
should be respected and to be quite
Frank aren't and it's about some of the
some of the issues that we've been
talking about on the committee over the
last couple of years which are very much
around the Pyramid of offending the the
cultural norms and I hate to say that
the cultural norms that make it okay to
abuse women online and at what point
does your online Predator turn into a
predator in real life and I think with
and the committee's working with some
experts to understand that pyramid of
offending and to to understand the
crossover between the virtual world and
the real world and it's all part of how
can we do better how can we make sure
that we uh that we address the root
causes of male violence against women
just finally I'm interested to get your
view quickly on how rich you see that's
getting on one concept of MP I spoke to
recently said that you had a zero
percent chance of winning the next
election now he put it at one in five
just share that analysis no I think it's
a lot better than that I'm really
pleased that we have Russia's prime
minister I supported him back in the
summer and I think that he's
doing okay
um it's a long way to go to the next
general election I think I want to see
us come up with some offers particularly
for female voters I want to see us get
the economy back on track I think that's
really important what kind of things for
female voters what okay so I think and
Rishi spoke about this in the summer
we've got to make women feel safe and
we've just been talking about that I
also want to see more action around the
Women's Health strategy to see some real
uh some real effort put into that so
some of the uh and I hesitate to say
some of the Forgotten conditions you
know the massive weights that we have in
Gynecology at the moment and I want to
make sure that we we come up with some
some good work around child care we know
that the pandemic clobbered the economic
well-being of women and I would love to
see us prioritize how we are focusing on
getting women into better jobs so I
think I'm right and saying that women
are more likely to vote for labor the
men right they are at the moment we have
to change that yeah okay thank you very
much indeed Caroline makes uh there